honestly everybody has an interest in
this because we all have an interest in
being healthier longer my name is Tony
arson I'm author of a new book called
100-plus how the coming age of longevity
will change everything from careers in
relationships family of faith you know I
was writing a regular column for tech
central station at the time maybe you
remember it now I rate for tech news
world as well aside from doing books and
I was looking around for a topic and one
night I turned on the TV and there was
this reality TV program The Swan an
extreme makeovers you remember those two
and I saw these people who were
radically changing their lives with
plastic surgery I remember this one
scene of these two people sitting on the
edge of a bed crying because they were
so happy they had managed to they had a
tummy tuck or something and now they
were thin and they were so happy and and
it got me thinking you know I wonder
what else is out there what other kinds
of technologies exist that can help us
change our lives for the better and I
started digging around and I found a lot
of stuff and then I got really excited i
found nanotechnology and gene therapy
and tissue engineering regenerative
medicine all these things and i realized
that a lot is going on that most people
don't know about that's really going to
radically change not only how long we
live how healthy we are and and so I
wanted to write a book not only so that
people know about it but also so that
people can push harder for it to come to
market faster because all of this stuff
exists in the lab regenerative medicine
growing new body parts for parts that
are diseased all of that exists in the
lab but getting it from the lab to the
everyday person if there's often a large
time to lay in I want people to know
about it so we can push for that to
happen faster so that we can be
healthier longer and more productive
a lot of this technology sounds like
science fiction you know if I say to you
guess what scientists have grown a
brand-new human bladder for children and
completely fixed them of their disease
you might say oh wow that sounds like
that sounds like something from a
science-fiction book but it's not it's
real dr. Anthony Atala at wake forest
university has done it in fact he did it
in 1999 and didn't talk about it until
2006 because he wanted to make sure it
actually worked he didn't want people
attacking it was work and saying oh you
know you shouldn't be messing with us
throwing human organs in the lab with
with people to own stem cells that
sounds crazy right but it's not crazy
it's here it's real and bladders are
only the beginning windpipes have been
grown there was a big case in the wall
street journal a man in Iceland had a
cancerous tumor the size of a golf ball
on his throat and he was going to die
chemotherapy wasn't working and the
scientists said look you have a choice
you can die or we can try to grow you in
your windpipe in the lab and so what did
he choose chose to live they used a new
technique this time he created the
windpipe out of and net synthetic
nanomaterials based on a 3d model of his
windpipe took some of his own stem cells
seeded it in the synthetic structure
incubated it in the lab for a few days
and then implanted it took out the old
one of course and implanted the new one
and today he's cancer-free he's
completely cured and that's such big
news I mean it's really really exciting
but it's only experimental I mean the
average Joe on the street can't access
that yet and I want to see a day where
they can and there's other things that
are going on in the lab when researchers
have grown brand new hearts for rats US
researchers say they've grown a beating
heart in a lab hasn't been done for
humans yet but they're working on pig
hearts no and I think they'll be
successful with that and if they are
that's very exciting even at the pig
level because right now pig parts are
used for human transplants so and heart
disease is the number one killer in
America lungs of growing than grown in
the lab all of these things so we have
the potential to get a big enough parts
list so we can keep repairing
humans kind of like we prepared vintage
cars right you have a car that you love
and you just keep replacing parts as it
breaks down and I see a day and then
hopefully in a not too distant future it
depends on how long it takes to get from
lab to consumer where we'll be able to
repair ourselves and live a lot longer
and healthier first off every scientists
will say that the biggest barrier are
the the scientific barriers right and
we've been able to grow lungs in the lab
for rats but can we do it for humans
right I believe that it can be done and
the US military think so as well they've
put a lot of money the US Department of
Defense has put a lot of money into
regenerative medicine because of course
they want to be able to replace parts
for soldiers were wounded when they come
back for war from warm so the technical
difficulties are the biggest one and
then there's the regulatory problems the
FDA the various agencies that oversee
these kind of techniques and then
training doctors right because this is a
brand new thing so you've got it and
you've got this bold generation of
doctors out there who this is going to
be brand new and really big news too so
then there's the training aspect and and
all of that so it's going to take some
time nobody wants to sit in an old folks
home and and whether away that is
absolutely not the goal the brain
question is a good question and you know
I the lower hanging fruit in the
regenerative medicine basket is the
things like the heart and the lungs and
the you know and the bladders and the
windpipes but when it comes to the brain
that's something different it's more
difficult we don't understand it that
well and so I think that's going to be
the biggest barrier especially since
Alzheimer's is such a big problem but
I'm hopeful on that there's a number of
folks in the technology community who
are working on this question and by the
way the one of the points I make in the
book is that biology is quickly becoming
an information technology just like
software programs are based on ones and
zeros now that we've sequenced the human
genome we have four letters for humans
it's the DNA a CT mg and because we have
that ability to reverse engineer the
human body we're going to be able to
understand it better and happy
and repair it right and so to that end
people like Paul Allen the co-founder of
Microsoft has put in a ton of money into
it the Paul Allen Institute in Seattle
to reverse-engineer the human brain and
they've matched a the genome of the
human brain of a mouse brain and they're
really working on that and then you've
got other companies like IBM and Sony
most people tend to think of those
companies as you know if they make
computers right I mean one of one of
their big dreams right now is to reverse
engineer the human brain iBM is putting
a lot of resources into this and Sony is
also working on it so it's very exciting
when we could live to be 150 years old
in a healthy state then when you're 90
years old you feel more like you're 40
right and so we'll have people who are
older but still really healthy and so
they'll have all that experience and
families will grow of course you will
not only have your mother-in-law you'll
have your grandmother-in-law around so I
think family will become more
complicated and more diverse they'll be
different types of pairings you could
imagine a 25 year old getting married to
a 90 year old and that nine year old
still has a lot of time left if they're
looking at a life expectancy of 150
years so lots of interesting things can
happen on the family front on the
economic front will be around a lot
longer so we'll be able to have what
there's a potential to have many types
of jobs because we'll have time to go
back and retrain you know in right now
today if you wanted to be a lawyer and a
doctor you can't really it's tough to do
that because both of those careers take
a lot of training but in the future if
you want to try both of those things and
maybe even be an entrepreneur as well
you've got time to go back to school and
learn new things and meet new people and
and really use your experience and
wisdom to create new things and try new
things so I think that's really exciting
with a lot of the regenerative medicine
and the tissue engineering like creating
new windpipes in the lab or new bladders
in the lab the scientists are actually
using adult stem cells from the actual
people so there aren't a lot of ethical
erations with that on in terms of you
know the embryonic stem cell debate or
or anything like that I guess there's
still the question of playing God though
as you said and you know some people
oppose the idea of extending health
expectancy using science any kind of
science stem cell or personalized
medicine or anything like that because
they don't think we should be messing
with nature right because if we mess
with nature all these things could go
wrong maybe we'll overpopulate and run
and the earth will just get destroyed
and there there's new diseases will be
unleashed or for any of these
catastrophic things that they imagine
and I think it's important that we think
about the ramifications of what we're
doing you know how are we going to keep
the earth clean and healthy while fewer
people are dying but ultimately I don't
I don't think any of those arguments
work I think that that is important to
work as hard as we can to keep ourselves
healthy or longer and and having more
experienced people around helps us come
up with better ideas and more
innovations honestly everybody has an
interest in this because we all have an
interest in being healthier lung